Jimbo Fisher Texas A&M s head coach and
we did a little research coach we found
out that you played quarterback in
college at was that Division three or
Division two or one double-a give me an
idea of how good you were
Salem college we were Salem college and
I was cooked about and son Terry about
that's real good went to national
playoffs two years like the Ville was
acting NAIA one which is like the vision
to and then he transfer he keep changed
and went to Sanford University and got
me to transfer with him when I finished
up at Stanford University with it how
good a quarterback were you we did all
right we did all right we sued around a
little bit make the play won some games
did okay were you the division three
Player of the Year yes Wow yes look at
you look at you who plays the who plays
quarterback now on the NFL the way you
played in college oh that was a shorter
guy five nine you don't say you know and
I guess it'd be a Russell Wilson
constantly could run with agile I mean
could you had to you had to create but
we threw it a bunch we're doing a bunch
back then you know for that time that
day and time you know you didn't spread
out have all the shotgun and all the
things you did then I had to create with
your legs mixed around a little
quarterback running options at times but
from a size standpoint like that when I
grew up when I grew up
Doug Flutie now now you wouldn't know
Doug Flutie but we were the same side
that's kind of you scrambled you had to
run around to find lane to throw you
couldn't see back there all the time
yeah Flutie I thought was one of the
more underrated quarterbacks certainly
college ball dollar and ever played the
game one of the most dynamic guys
probably affect this team and what he
did what he did at BC and guy when
Heisman his size and the games he won
the team's of glass I mean what a
phenomenal phenomenal player he was
alright you walk off the private jet you
got the band blaring the trumpet
sounding what was that feeling like as
you as you landed at am people here a
phenomenal extremely nice and polite and
very classy guy excellent and then just
been you know embrace very warmly and
and in the back of my mind thinking okay
we got to get this thing going we gotta
win some games
how long you
have you been thinking about this I
wasn't right at the end I mean the right
is a variant that and you know the last
week when they called and called my
representation to do it and it you know
really caught me off guard a little bit
you know had no plans on anything like
that happening and there wasn't very
long at all if the money was the same
would you still take an am very possible
yes I mean you know you don't like to
move but sometimes it is and it's
inevitable that changes are made like
God puts things in front of for reasons
I was very happy where I was loved where
it was and everything else and there's
some resources it's an untapped
potential and you've got a great
recruiting base and I had a great I
didn't have a great relationship our
threat president ad we were a very good
relationship I've known Scott wood where
he was an LSU when we flipped that thing
down there with Coe Sabin and I knew his
commitment to doing things he was in
Washington and they were ever turned
that thing around and and the direction
they're going and it was it was a great
challenge be able to come down here and
there's something I just want to be a
part of but it feels like there was
there's too I don't know exposed
feelings here harder feelings with
leaving Florida State or what happened
didn't happen
explain that to no no I mean billions I
guess anytime you leave it the president
asked me on Friday if I was gonna make a
diss coach the game make decision on
Saturday night Sunday morning what our
future was because I only had about it
we know had been contact during that
week that that was a possibility and he
and the president asked me to make a
decision on Friday which I did about he
called me in so I went over to his
office around 11:30 probably somewhere
in that range and we sit down and talked
and I say no I you know make a decision
for the bedroom of the team and and I
said we keep it completely quiet between
you and I and then I'll have a team
meeting at two o'clock and tell our
players and which is always the toughest
by far and what we were doing and so I
had a team meeting at 2 o'clock but I
guess about 10 minutes before somehow I
could I'd ever say anything it I'll have
no idea how it got out because the only
people were talked with he and I and
even knew and about 10 minutes before
their but they worked the kids were
already in the meeting room when I
walked in the meeting room and total and
it was extremely hard very tough had no
plans of ever doing that if I was I'd
already done a game plan we've worked
all week and rescheduled you LM to be a
game I mean you know you wouldn't we
wouldn't have done that so there was no
inclination of going anywhere and so I
walked in at two o'clock and had to tell
her team and it was very very tough and
I was on that was tough on me but I love
those kids and I always have and but you
know they understood and I've had a mane
of until we mean call me since I've been
here and totally understand and we still
have communication on things and but
it's extremely tough
he's Jimbo Fisher Texas A&M head coach
you said it was a no-brainer to go to
A&M my well as I said back in him when I
started to read about after I got here
with you know was that Woodward the
commitment they're having here that the
resources wait to have here in the
recruiting base they have here and you
know there was some opportunities here
that just like you say for the
betterment of everything from your
family to everything I have to Brenda's
respective love Forks they'd always have
I was a Florida State fan growing up and
but the commitment in their relationship
he and I had and the vision of which
they had for what the future they want
to be and you know you want to be one of
the first guys to be able to help them
go do that what are you doing today on
the road recruiting what town right now
I'm at door Houston you know it's it's
it's it's weird when you like it's a
whole new area for you how often did you
recruit in Texas when you're at Florida
State
well not but I was at LSU I recruited
over here when I was in lesterland
and I've been in the area we always had
a lot of taxes fighters and we recruited
Texas last year we recruited then we saw
Marvin Wilson as number one to even
attack on the country out of Houston so
now area now you know we're in such a
global world the national world kids are
going everywhere in it if you don't look
at players it's not the regional world
where everybody just counts the Florida
rare state executive everybody is going
everywhere so in the coach you know
you've recruited almost every state in
the United States when you really look
you go down and break a roster down on
most schools you're up and down East
Coast West Coast South North everywhere
so we all have relationships all the way
across what you think of people
responding to you thrown out the
Christmas tree when you left Florida
State well what that was I had no idea
the guys who come to put my Christmas
tree up that week said they got it out
take oh just broke what happened was
broke so I put a new one up and he said
so we'll get rid
the other okay so they set it on the
curb for it to be picked up that was
what it was there's a new Christmas tree
in my house it's still in my house I
mean that's exactly what that guy I
didn't throw it out I didn't throw it I
was acting it works there was a group
who comes in and puts the lights and
everything across the house cuz I'm
never they know you're always on record
recruiting we had a group Esposito's who
comes and does it may call me a Jimbo's
this thing's over ten years old and it
woke up sorry I thought you need a new
one so I said okay put a new one up so
they put a new one up and set the other
one on the curb behind that what are you
gonna do throw it out what are you gonna
do with all your 40 state gear I'm sure
there'll be family and friends I'll keep
some of it nobody family and friends
that that remember Billy and they'll be
family and friends and people who you
know that are there that I'll give it to
well good luck with the mission there
you got ten years so I'm expecting at
least one national title in 10 years
there Jimbo well me too
only only one I will say I don't ever
plan I want to bring all the bunch all
right safe travels thanks for joining us
coach for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show ass
[Music]